I'm going to pretend half that applauses
for me even though I know deep down it
is not nice um Lucia you think like 30%
of it was for me
Tennessee's great either way
I'm at the Oscars with Michael J Fox a
DeLorean while wearing future shoes all
I have to do is sing the Skylar sister
song from Hamilton in front of the world
and I will have completed my entire
bucket list look around look around at
how lucky we are to be alive right now
Angelica Eliza and Peggy look around
look around okay we gave you the whole
thing okay fine I won't be in the room
that happen okay keep going we were here
presenting the Award for achievement in
film editing because we're talking about
influencers and influencers I want to
mention how much we all go to editors
there is a nominee here tonight to
depend on editors to show off their best
work here are the nominees for
achievement in film editing arrived Joe
Walker hacksaw edge John Gilbert
hell or high water Jake Roberts voila
land Tom cross moonlight NAT Sanders and
joy Macmillan and the Ashley Goldstein
hacksaw Ridge John Gilbert
this is the first officer and second
nomination for John Gilbert he received
his first nomination in this category
for the Lord of the Rings the Fellowship
of the Ring
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow unbelievable and it needs good
material and the story of Desmond das
and his courage and selflessness was as
good as you get
so that was a great start for me I want
to thank my my team in Australia Callie
Turner Cathy Freeman I hope you're
watching bill mechanic for supporting me
and introducing me to Mel Mel I had a
fabulous time working on this film with
you and your great director and I hope
this plenty more with us came from my
wife my wife Karen over there I couldn't
do this without you my love up there's
my max & lily where are you yep and blue
chair and Amelia back in New Zealand I
hope you're watching thank you very much
I appreciate this so much
[Applause]